how did you feel about Kenya going on
Wendy Williams and putting it on blast
that you are the highest-paid housewife
on Atlanta don't check for me unless you
got a check for me season 12 of The Real
Housewives of Atlanta
oh this year is gonna be good you know
every year they always say that I'm
always the one miss like when we start
taping I'm like I don't know about this
but every year I say that and this year
oh I'm just so happy with how things
ended up coming together meaning that I
feel like the best seasons are when we
have a lot of personal stories along
with the drama yeah there is a lot of
personal story we mostly just seemed
personal story so far focusing a lot on
Porsha and Dennis for these first few we
first started taping apparently they had
a lot going on honey did you know all
that was going on I didn't know
everything that was going on because you
know Porsha nah we don't talk as much
you know outside of the girls so I
didn't really know what was going on
with her and after last year I said I
wasn't saying anything else about
anything that I've heard no especially
not you know dealing with the Porsche
and in that situation I don't want us to
continue to have drama like that was
starting to annoy me that she and I just
became the drama every year all of a
sudden you know and so I was like I
didn't want that anymore I really wanted
her to focus more on her and getting her
groove back she just wasn't being her
normal self so she wasn't really getting
made up I had saw her she didn't have on
heels she didn't have a makeup on she I
was like are you that wasn't the girl
that I know the Porsha that I know is
normally you know glam and hills and all
of that and so my whole point to her was
do not let whatever is happening in the
relationship get you down because at the
bottom the bottom line is you are a
mother now you may or may not be doing
this journey or you know as a single mom
who knows but you still got to pull it
together and get your groove back get
your groove back
keep your career on point I was like you
cannot allow everything to fall apart
just because
your whatever's happening in your
personal life so pull a together girl
and that's what I was seeing her I
talked to Portia ahead of the season and
she said the dynamic of the group has
really changed now that every main
person is a mom mm-hmm do you feel that
too
I mean I guess though I mean I've been a
mom so it's not feeling different for me
I think it's definitely more different
for a Porsche and Kenya because they're
new to the mom world yeah you know they
can relate to each other in that way now
and it's kind of like a bonding thing
happening between people who really
weren't cool obviously Kenya unfortunate
right cool before and now they bonded
over being mothers which is a great
thing you know they still was holding on
to other dramas outside of that oh okay
bring it up Kenya when you heard she was
coming back into the fold
clearly no I was all down for that I
like to say I had a hand in that one I
think we saw that hand last season when
you roped her in Tom but his event yeah
stirred up some unexpected drama yeah I
didn't even think it was in a turn left
like that I just really wanted Kenya to
show her face my whole goal with that
situation was that I did not want us to
go a whole season and the fans never got
a chance to see Kenya pregnant I said
that didn't make sense to me I'm like
Kenya all these years we've been
invested in her finding love having a
baby and here it is she's pregnant and
the fans are not gonna see her one time
right and I really didn't take in
consideration other people's feelings I
guess but
this is a bunch of bullish there Cynthia
is doing considering she had every
opportunity to tell me she didn't tell
me because she did not want me to know
yeah me me all up in her feelings about
that yeah she was I was I didn't know
what was gonna go lift like that though
like so much so that she took a step
back from the group and almost from the
show and I don't know if she was ever
choosing to step away from the shop from
what I understand she's always said that
nobody is ever going to stop her chick
or stop her from you know dealing with
the show so I don't think that stopped
her I have no idea you know why she was
wasn't on the first couple of episodes
because I know that's you know talked
about a lot and there's so many
different opinions yeah what is going on
I don't feel like anybody any one of us
stopped her from being on the episode
okay yeah she we just sat down with Nene
and she said she would not give tenure
that much credit it's how she put it
yeah so I mean it was basically what I'm
saying I mean we didn't have anything
for to do with her not being on it so I
want to get your responses to some
things Nene sentiment in every we just
did with her she said these girls to me
all seem to want to be the queen or
though the one that everybody think of
when they say housewives I don't think
that that's possible I think there's one
queen and there's a lot of princesses
[Laughter]
that's that ego thing don't get me wrong
I'm not trying to claim the Queen ain't
like I feel like everybody on this show
is the queen one person can't carry it
so with that being said much love to her
I'm glad she's here but I would never
say that there is one queen and a whole
bunch of princesses because those first
two episodes went along just fine people
should tune in and and life went on
everybody has fans on this show and so
that's just out how I will leave it you
know to me yeah kind of in that same
discussion how did you feel about Kenya
going on Wendy
and putting it on blast that you are the
highest-paid housewife on Atlanta Oh God
I mean she's the top biller that's not
true so who makes the most in the line
that makes the most money okay okay so
if I was coming for anybody's purse and
bag it would be Kandi's so I'm not going
to confirm neither here nor there
well what I will say is I've seen what
the blog said for years and they've
never had my salary right okay
Bravo has treated me well as well as
they treat everybody well on this show
they take care of us and I'm happy with
what they pay me and I'm leaving it at
that I do not care what everybody else
gets paid so and I don't want them to
care about what I'm getting paid
can you get a text message or a phone
call after that interview oh girl what
she's just like well she thought it was
funny she felt like it well I I just
need to let him know I was like hey man
I'm staying out of that I mean I just
don't I just don't feel like it's
appropriate for us to talk about like
how much we make like that and I don't
even know like when I see those like
reports a book come out about how much
each person makes on the show yeah like
who's giving them this information like
who's really sending it in to say oh
this person may I know I'm telling
anybody how much I make so who was
giving you this information it's not
truth I can tell you since at least
season three I've seen anything I've
seen that reported my it's never been
right okay also in our child Nene she
said she has never gotten physical I've
never been the fighter know not a
fighter but I'm sorry worries but you
know my kid why people mostly think that
I have fought because I could say
something that make you feel like you've
been hit so I get it thank your face
just saying it all right now I mean we
saw last year she pulled the cameraman
you do not with some camera I mean it
was one thing if the camera didn't see
it remember that one years just like
what the camera didn't see it this time
camera saw it so it's like I don't know
if you can necessarily deny with Sun
film from the trailer of this season it
looks like things get to an almost
physical place again or maybe a couple
of times a couple of times a few times
this season
the girls I don't know I always say they
have too many they're drinking oh yeah
and then some of them like some of them
like start talking too much when they
just drink some of them get kind of mean
when they drink and so I always say I'm
glad I don't drink this what's going
down when you drink it oh you're
startled witness it yeah we've had a few
moments where security had this security
break them up you do something yeah I'm
talking about personal story you've got
a lot going on in your life a baby is on
the way baby number three mm-hmm are we
ready as the nursery prepared how's
everything in there Siri is still
getting done okay I am behind schedule
I should have been had all this done and
I have not I am like rushing I'm in a
rush right now man I'm in a mad rush to
get all my stuff together how does a
spheal about becoming a big brother he's
excited he keeps saying oh my little
sister bye baby sister when she gets
here oh it was so cute one day we still
have one of his little small patties
next to a regular-sized toilet in the
hallway and he one day you said I'm
gonna teach my baby sister how to stand
up and pee in this toilet why being it
[Music]
okay how does Riley feel about the new
baby I see
she's well you know in the beginning she
always says we don't need any more kids
right but everybody's excited we see in
the trailer - it looks like you guys
have taken on more businesses and you
ain't in that one [ __ ] expect on that
side well okay my husband is very smart
very intelligent but lately he's been a
little bit overdoing it uh-huh it's just
he's decided to add all of these
different businesses at the same time
and I just felt like we should have like
you know get one move in before we start
the next one it's just a lot at the same
time and don't get me wrong I believe
that we should go after our dreams and
obviously I like to multi-task yes you
know you're a hustler but I just felt
like six new businesses at the same time
that you all trying to start at once
it's a lot when you already got about
six right you know okay here we go here
we go wrap things up here season 12 what
are you most looking forward to the fans
getting to experience this year oh oh
well on season 12 obviously seeing all
these babies is awesome but the girls in
there drama is so funny it's like new
dramas new dramas it's not like the old
stuff being rehash just like new stuff
and then you get to see if people are
gonna be put on blast this year you know
and I love when you know people tell
lies their little fibs and then they go
back and play the footage on it oh
that's gonna happen multiple times this
year Oh is there one big drama in it or
is it a bunch of like it's a bunch of
little dramas this year and I think well
you know y'all like to call them friends
of the show but I would say you know
Marlo and Tanya they are damn near on
the show as much as the house while
after that clmu and Marlo at the
trampoline park I was like where's
Marlowe speech I don't even know this
whole story
I would love for Marlo to have a peach
because
she has a lot happening in her life
right now which we will still see it and
you know I think it's gonna be good TV
is there anything that you're dreading
having to relive or watch back oh well
ok you know what I would say for me I
didn't have as much drama with the girls
this year I did have like one moment
where you know I was like okay girl but
not as much drama with the girls let's
say as we're as much as they are having
got it let's just say so this year for
me I'm pretty happy with how things are
going I'm mostly dealing with my own
personal stuff of waiting for my baby to
get here and then also you know the
thing you know what my husband started
you know that's a lot that's a lot
there's a lot but for the show itself
you know I don't want to give away
anything that's happening but it's a lot
of drama with these girls it always is
[Music]